[Music]
foreign
oh you're totally serious
all right here's the situation the
wizard gave me superpowers and then
everybody got superpowered
now the daughters of Atlas are coming to
hunt us but we come there in gifts
that's a hard pass that's a hard pass
look I might not have as much experience
as you because I'm not like super old
but I've seen all of the Fast and
Furious movies and it's all about family
endless now
we do
[Applause]
[Music]
we are a dwarf
we will annihilate everything
champions of this realm can do nothing
to stop us
you are very menacing I just want you to
know that
which is in the last few years the
wizard gave me superpowers
I mean everybody got superpowers
all right here's the situation
is told the power of the Gods
he ripped it from our father's core okay
I feel like maybe I should be writing
all this down
was child your world will not survive
this
you want these Powers come get them
now we're here all right
we have one job to do save the world
I don't know how we fight powers like
this
I can't do this take my powers back you
came to me so you would take them back
right
I speak Millennia
searching for worthy champion
you know exactly what must be done
what are you doing I have to do this we
end this now
we do
now we're here
[Music]
I'm an idiot
it's your time
I don't deserve these Powers if I'm
being honest like what am I even
contributing
there's already a superhero with a red
suit with a lightning bolt on it
it's literally huge
he's so manly and Batman so cool and I'm
just me
[Music]
I feel like a fraud it doesn't matter
um anyway a wizard gave me super powers
well then everybody got super powers but
who's everyone going
to fight crime
okay
now everyone's kind of like doing their
own thing and I'm the only one trying to
keep it together
[Music]
you understand I'm a pediatrician
right
come on
the fate of the world depends on it
[Music]
children's taught the power of all the
gods
very
[Music]
very look I might not have as much
experience as you because I'm not super
old like you but I've seen all of the
Fast and Furious movies Lady it's all
about family
[Music]
the world will not survive this
I don't know how we fight powers like
this
I think I know how to fix this dude but
I really don't
Worthy
now go fight for your family go fight
for the world
I just threw a truck and a dragon I love
my life
[Music]
foreign